اخبار ايجابيه مشاهدينا تلقتها اوكرانيا
خلال الايام الماضيه بعد اعلان الولايات
المتحده
تعجيل تسليم دبابات ابرز لاوكرانيا يوم
الثلاثاء اعلن البانتاجون انه سيمنح
اوكرانيا دبابات ابرامز ام واحد اي واحد
وهو ما يعني انه يمكن تسليم الدبابات في
الخريف المقبل وبشكل اسرع ما كان متوقعا
المتحدث باسم قال ان الدبابات المرسله الى
اوكرانيا سيتم ادخال تحسينات عليها لتصبح
قريبه من الدبابه ام واحد اي اثنين
والاحدث من ابرز سيتم تزويد الدبابات
بمدفع من عيار 120 ملم اضافه لمدفع رشاش
ثقيل من عيار 50 ملي مترا بالاضافه الى
دروع متطوره على الصعيد الميدانيه يقول
الجيش الامريكي ان لدبابه ابرامز قدرات
ناريه قاتله وقدره على المناوره بشكل
استثنائي وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
اعلن عزم واشنطن ارسال 31 دبابه الى كاز
وهو ما يكفي لتجهيز كتيبه الدبابات
اوكرانيه كامله بعد الاعلان الامريكي حيث
قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
ان التبرع بابرم سيكون عبثا لان هذه
الدبابات ستحترق تماما مثل كل الدبابات
الاخرى